they're volunteers picking up the covert
dead no one else will
the kindness of strangers in the most
awful of circumstances
they all have jobs now on hold so they
can help in this national crisis
they've been collecting bodies in their
makeshift ambulance since first light
this is their fifth in a few hours all
carried from homes where coronavirus
struck
and where they breed their last without
ever getting to hospital
when they arrive at the crematorium it
is absolutely packed
and they're at the back of a long queue
of funerals
this is pretty astonishing because
almost everywhere you
look there are ambulances carrying
a number of dead people there are
something like 42
ambulances that we've counted that go
all the way
down this road and the crematorium is
working
non-stop as the numbers of deaths in
india continue to rise
along with the spike in coronavirus
cases
they don't have time to wait it's going
to be a while before the funeral can be
held
the crematorium's already got a backlog
and they're furiously building more
pyres
and the volunteers have had a call to
pick up another body and this time it's
personal
it's pritam's cousin they're taking
incredible risks
doing a job they don't need to do whilst
coronavirus tears through their
own families his cousin was a successful
businessman
jaspal a father of three with two
daughters in london
and a third in canada
it's close to 40 degree heat and
collecting your own relative
in a pandemic is not easy either
physically or emotionally
and they've all suffered
their families watch from a distance
there's a lot of fear about now
as well as covert restrictions keeping
them apart
today we are picking up his cousin uh
two days back i i picked up on my own
uncle
and he died because he couldn't supply
him oxygen i was working in the mortuary
van
i couldn't pick up the call and the
moment i was able to receive the call he
was already passed away
so it's it's really tough for us the
next crematorium
is as intensely busy as the last
it feels like the whole of india is
burning right now
and everyone's affected by this pratam
spends
minutes with his family he's not the
only one who doesn't have the luxury of
grieving
and this is all weighing heavily on them
if we got emotional we will not be able
to do this
we have to be strong we have to cope up
with this
is spending his days surrounded by death
his own parents are ill with covet
and he's also been sick with it but he
wants to contribute
and this is his way
every home visit he and the team are
entering a dangerous
infected zone again and there's shock
and distress inside it's another father
another breadwinner who leaves two
daughters and a wife
how can somebody who's lost everything
put into words what this means she says
my girls are all alone now
the end had not been easy for davinder
singh or his family
full of battles and frustration
there's an undignified struggle down two
flights of stairs
the family hadn't been able to get him
enough oxygen or a hospital bed
and their neighbors who knew this feel
their sorrow it could easily be them
next
without these strangers helping they
couldn't even transport the body to the
crematorium
a mother and her two daughters united in
their anger that this need not have
happened
and these mass funerals could have been
avoided
i really feel that there is a big
failure of judiciary
of the nation so many people who cheated
me on cylinders
wouldn't give me facilities on time
and my father couldn't get anything on
time everything got delayed everything
everything got delayed no reports on
time
no medicines one time no cylinders
nothing
india is suffering and too many believe
that it's not covered that's killing but
the mismanagement of it
the loss is very personal but there's a
collective pain in the country
alex crawford sky news delhi